now I don't know about you but as I
mentioned earlier I've had enough of the
pathetic attempts by Democrats to try to
take credit for president Trump's
booming economy now it's a lie that
former President Obama has been peddling
now for three years the longest streak
of job creation in American history by
far a streak that still continues by the
way thanks Obama calls right now
remember who started it of course
Obama's media acolytes they just echo
his empty claims Trump's greatest
accomplishment he's not screwing up
brock obama's economy ten percent less
job creation under trump that under
obama he talks about is the benefits of
the economy did he do any of those
things know he's a benefiting from
Barack Obama's economy there's but just
about every measure Barack Obama's
economy was much stronger I have a novel
idea tonight let's introduce a concept
called facts into this equation first
off Obama benefited from the national
natural recovery associated with the
terrible recession but even then
economic growth ground to a halt by the
end of his presidency it shrunk to a
measly 1.6 percent during his last year
in office in 2016 the unemployment rate
stood at four point seven percent and
real middle-class wage growth was flat
business sentiment was relatively low
probably as a consequence of the nine
hundred billion dollars worth of
regulatory red tape from the Obama
administration consumer confidence was
flagging as well and the Dow was sitting
just above 18,000 on the eve of the 2016
election but we all remember that all
changed the night Trump was elected we
will embark upon a project of national
growth and renewal
I will harness the creative talents of
our people and we will call upon the
best and brightest to leverage their
tremendous talent for the benefit of all
and he made good on that promise
business sentiment immediately spiked
consumer confidence skyrocketed almost
immediately it hit another 15-year high
last week and the Dow soared it's now
nearing 30,000 points nearly double what
it was before Trump's election now
that's great news for the millions of
Americans with 401ks and IRAs and then
of course there were the tax cuts we've
cut taxes we've taken care of
regulations cut more than any other
president in the history of our country
and we did that in three years instead
of eight years remember the tax cut was
the biggest tax cut in the history of
our country it turns out that the money
Americans kept which Pelosi derided as
crumbs it boosted our economy beyond
what anyone expected or as the New York
Times put it a wave of optimism has
swept over American business leaders and
it's beginning to translate into the
sort of investment in new plants
equipment and factory upgrades that
bolsters economic growth Spurs job
creation and may finally raise wages
significantly well and it worked right
unemployment is now near an all-time
lows and the benefits of this are being
felt far and wide the unemployment rate
among African Americans Hispanic
Americans and Asian Americans has
reached record lows all-time never been
lower than what it is now
but some Democrats just can't accept
these amazing jobs numbers I'm saying
that the African American unemployment
is not the lowest has ever been unless
you count slavery we were fully employed
during slavery not even supposed to say
to that the fact is the unprecedented
prosperity that we're seeing today is
the opposite of what the so called
economic experts predicted back in 2016
in the event Donald wins I have no doubt
in my mind the the market tanks you will
see a market crash of historic
proportions if Trump becomes president
and implements all of his proposed
policies the
u.s. economy could take a one trillion
dollar hit I mean how are any of those
people still working after those
predictions all right well instead of
calamity we all know we're living in the
best economy in decades and most
Americans know whom to think a new
Gallup poll as we mentioned earlier
found that 62 percent credit Trump with
the booming economy compared to just 51
percent who said it's because of Obama
well no wonder the Democrats are trying
to steal though the economic limelight I
was thinking about this tonight if I
were a Democrat and I was looking at all
these numbers the charts the graphs and
just the facts about wages going up for
the lower income Americans the middle
income Americans I'd want to take credit
for all of that as well what else are
you gonna say to it and that's the angle